[Music]
hey guys let's talk about human
centipede
no okay basically let me explain we were
just all having a chat
and then somehow we got onto the topic
of the movie human centipede and then we
quickly stopped and said let's get this
on the podcast because if you're going
to talk about the human centipede movie
make sure that it is recorded make sure
it's recorded and distributed to the
masses um i have a very clear memory
first of all when that movie came out
everyone was saying it's this forbidden
movie and finally they've gone too far
and i was on tour at the time do you
remember this sona i do because that's
when i watch i'm gonna well that's what
i'm that's my point is that i'm on a
tour bus and i remembered once you
finally got somehow
a copy of it on your computer yeah from
the dark web on the dark web you were
streaming and so you went back with uh
with megan sinclair yes photographer for
the show and she you two went back in
the bus to this back area and shut the
door and watched it and at one point i
came in and looked at your faces and it
was if you had seen
a black hole that was uh devouring the
universe yes and you just had this look
of awe and horror
and
i thought we were going to have to stop
the bus at a hospital and have you guys
treated right for shock and then later
on i just had to so i watched human
centipede and then of course we started
doing um tons of bits we had a human
centipede menorah yeah
people should know too that this film
from 2010 is most people probably do
know this but the centipede is made up
of three humans that's right the front
the middle and the rear and they're all
stitched to each other by an evil doctor
yes mouth to ass yeah or yeah depends on
what i like
some people say mouth to ass i prefer
ass to mouth okay but it all depends
it's you say tomato i say tomato um
let's call the whole thing off the
original version actually of that song
written in the 30s was you say mouth to
ass i say ass to mouth let's call the
whole thing off the gershwins wanted um
i don't think it's the gershwins is it
not the gershwins i don't think so i
thought it was the gershwins uh i'm
gonna say cole porter let me check it up
if i'm right i'm gonna feel really good
about myself i'm pretty sure cole porter
wrote ask to mouth mouth to ass i can
tell you this that this is absolutely
the first time the human centipede and
cole porter have been referenced in the
same conversation sorry
second time
i was giving a lecture not long ago on
cole porter and i brought up
[Laughter]
human centipede and the whole crowd knew
exactly what i was talking about adam
said it's the gershwins is it okay oh
wow good for you um look at me yep that
was good very aware that i know
something that you i i thought well i
thought that was a good guess and i just
thought i thought it was cold porter for
some reason but the point is is human
centipede that's right back to us sewing
humans together
mouth mouth to ass um and the thing that
i was always trying to understand about
that movie and i did watch the movie is
there's a mad scientist obviously
because there's always a mad scientist
yeah uh my guess is uh his credentials
had been pulled at some point when he
proposed the whole mouth to ass sewing
and anyway he's this mad scientist and
he does this
and it's never clear why he thinks this
is a good idea it's never clear there's
no purpose for it and then he acts like
this is going to work somehow but they
all it doesn't it doesn't work they
it doesn't make any sense on any level
and so
i left the movie instead of being
titillated and shocked i left being
angry at the bad science i felt like he
had let me that was your issue with the
film my issue with the film is this is
he didn't think this through well maybe
it's a way to solve world hunger no
doesn't what are you talking about if it
worked if you could ingest someone's
feces and then and then expel your feces
into someone else's mouth you don't need
food
we would have figured that out so long
ago
we would have figured out you think that
that this guy cracked the uh if someone
was like oh my god and listen this
conversation is taking a very dark turn
and i understand if you're driving the
car right now you need to pull over and
stop it yeah but if ingesting feces was
something that worked and was pretty
good it had a lot of nutritional value i
think humans would have figured that out
year three
of human existence
they wouldn't have figured it out in
2010 when some coeds stumble into a
kooky german professor's
office in the rain and he just hits on
this idea no it doesn't work that's my
problem with it is i it's the rain these
two women go to this guy's house he is
creepy from the get-go and they're like
yeah this looks okay and they go into
his house wait a minute you're one to
talk you had you you took no social cues
when you were dating this is true i mean
i'm sorry you just i know you wouldn't
have been in that centipede yes yes
you've many times told me stories about
oh i met this guy he seemed really weird
he had a knife he kept itching his chest
uh he was wearing a shirt that said i
murder and what'd you do well we went to
a restaurant then we hung out at his
house in the basement and he what
happened well he tried to stab me a
couple times but i was like cut it out
cut it out what happened then well a
week later i called him up and we
decided to hang out in an old abandoned
mine
you did yeah what happened there he came
at me with a flame
like a torch and he tried to burn me and
i'm like hey knock it off with the
burning i just barely got away what then
well i'm gonna see him tomorrow
i'm meeting him
he's taken to me to see human centipede
he's taking me to see human centipede oh
really in a theater no it's his own
screening room he built out of human
skulls
oh
really what's it projected on just giant
sheets of human skin
oh
but i think it'll be okay that was you
when you were single you're you know
what i would argue with you but you're
100
i went on the four worst dates of my
life with the same guy yes i've told you
this yeah and i think that uh
by the fourth date i was like i loathe
this person but i i just i'm gonna just
do it anyway why i don't know i he was
cute i guess i don't know i mean so do
you think
you would be open to getting human
centipeded then i don't think i'd be
open to it but i could see myself like
i'm i'm judging these ladies who go into
this guy's house and he's like uh i'm
gonna drug you and whatever but i would
have probably done that yeah and i think
what would have happened is
he would have tried to sow you to the
other person
something you would have escaped run
through the woods but then come back the
next day oh say hey do you want to watch
this these four times do you want to
watch
yeah i've got a dvd
i've got a i got a dvd uh that's it's
pretty good it's uh escape from which
mountain that's the second one
the bigger moral quandary and i always
ask my wife amanda this because she's an
actor what would you guys do if you were
given a role in this movie and you're a
struggling actor like i'm assuming these
actors were uh-huh i mean the problem is
the problem is uh it's that chance you
take i think it's very hard to recover
from that role clearly so i think if
dame judi dench
had been in that movie if they had made
that movie in
1965 and dame judy dench had been in it
and she's a magnificent actress
i don't know that she could recover and
become a dame and become one of the
leading actors in the world maybe she
could you know that all her interviews
would be
well anyway i'm pleasure to be here i'm
so nice to have my you know second oscar
what a wonderful uh yes warning we've
got no questions about human centipede
imagine though if it was judy dench
helen mirren and ian mckellen yes this
is human centerpiece yeah they're the
three they were in it it was it was made
in 1965 and all of them
were in uh london's south end they were
really starving
they needed the work this human
centipede came out so it's
it's those three fantastic actors in
human centipede and then they all manage
to recover their careers and go on to
big things but if you bring it up they
just lose their minds we're not talking
about that
we're not talking about it
we don't know i mean it's very clear
with my publicist we are not talking
about human centipede but i'm sorry was
it your ass
wait whose jaw was strapped
to it'd be like was it dame judy dench
first then
and then ian mckellen like the order's
important and then you'd finally get ian
mckellen saying well i
you know i was very upset to be second i
think i should have been first i should
have been the first one receiving food
and then my feces should have been
passed on you know and and and he's
still ranting and raving about it 40
years later and then the quarantine hit
and they finally agreed to a zoom
reunion reread of the script
this is tourey's money
the three of them this it's to raise
money for a good cause you know to get
buy more mass and distribute them and
they're like well very well let's let's
do this uh oh stock and stormy night is
it yes it certainly is oh look
uh uh uh
i'm like in the rain it's a german
professor's home let's see let's go have
it yes yes we'll go have a look
what
drugged
wait a minute you're sewing my jaw to
her ass
you monster i think you can recover if
you were the first in the centipede if
you didn't eat any of the [ __ ] then i
think that you can recover your career
is fine after that so you're saying as
an actor not as a human who's been as an
actor yeah as someone who's been eating
[ __ ] on television for 28 years
uh i can tell you
that it's survivable okay you know
out there
on
tv being insulted by the best of them oh
god
yeah let's wrap this up before we
inevitably get to the point where we try
to figure out which position the three
of us are in in this thing
oh well that ends it very quickly that
is all right well onward to better
things but hey human centipede uh i
think there's some sequels god knows
what's in those but uh check it out wait
why am i promoting this why are you
pronouncing i don't know
available wherever things are shown
i don't know that was terrible i
apologize so bad